wait this is weird because i feel like
we're um
closer than we are
i know we've never met never met i'm a
big fan
yes
i'm a big fan
we
kind of met through dms
we did i like slid into your dms like in
a good way the movie came out like in a
good way but i respected it beyond it
like in a like i'm just a fan it was the
coolest thing
people don't do that man it's like i
feel like when other people get success
in our field
there's like oh well someone else got
this thing i didn't have like i just
it's like i'm like so psyched for
everyone yeah i i a few years back um
somebody said something to me where it
was like there's enough room for
everybody and you really see it once you
start moving in that direction yeah that
scarcity complex is real toxic yeah also
i think comedy is in a really weird
place and the community is even in a
worse place i also think a lot of
comedians don't like comedy like they're
not comedy fans it's like which i
understand they're fans of themselves
correct they're fans of their own comedy
and
to me it's like when i'm at the comedy
store and there's someone new i'm like i
want to go see that per like we cuz what
team making tv and movies and stuff has
taken from us is like the magic of being
able to escape in it so it's like the
things that most people use to relax
movies tv we can't relax you watch tv or
movie or like i auditioned for that i
should have gotten that yeah did i get
that it's like not fun that's why i like
reality so much i think that's
fascinating yeah like 90 day fiance and
the other one locked up what's the lock
up one lock up love after just love
after lock up that one's all your future
i love lacey she's on the to-do list
um i have not seen that i did watch love
is blind do you remember that show i
love his yeah i didn't watch that you
didn't watch it was netflix right i did
i did i was very into it
the problem is i have trouble watching
uh
reality shows because it makes me so
uncomfortable that these people have to
go back into the world
oh i used to work on like a jerry
springer type show what i was the guy
that used to carry the camera as people
ran off stage so like i used to watch
the worst of it i was a cameraman for
the bill cunningham show that used to be
on pix what
what did you learn about human nature um
that people love to be on tv and they'll
do anything to do it and they'll out
each other and say terrible things about
each other just to be on television
and the producers of those shows are
really like doing really bad wild things
okay and then it was probably signed to
mdas about this but let's go and it was
a dude i have very open
here's the airbnb
most of them expired number two in order
for an nda i got very into this with the
britney thing because i offered to pay
people's nda violation fees if they came
forward if they worked for brittany or
in any capacity to come forward because
everyone's so scared like i saw an nda
in order for an nda to matter at all the
person has to take you to court it costs
them like 300 grand when you violate an
nda to take you to court and then
they're going to look guilty if they
take you to court for violating you did
you help anybody yeah i got a lot of
weird emails wow
i was like i feel like i should maybe
just stay out of there she's back
bitch is back dog the bounty hunter's
back i thought he and the taliban
there's a lot back right now i feel like
the taliban never left but they did go
out of style for a hot minute and they
did do a reboot they saw the reboots we
were doing they were like you rebooted
roseanne and say by the bell like they
had like an hr meeting yeah yeah we're
really into nostalgia that's the big
thing that's selling right now is
nostalgia
so i was like i want to hear the
backstory of this helmet
the taliban is back like that can we get
the true hollywood story on the taliban
i did watch a documentary on it i guess
there was one on
netflix and um it was it's brutal i mean
they had like straight up roman coliseum
style
executions at like baseball fields yeah
i don't think they're good people i
don't you don't have to like
persuade me
um that's wild let me ask you how did
you get a job as a cameraman um
i just like made any way to make money
for a while but how would you like you
didn't have to be like a trained
cinematographer no they were like they
didn't they didn't want that they were
paying me under the table and whatnot
okay copy that come on yeah okay got it
i got to like film all the lie detectors
and stuff so i knew what was gonna go
down before it went down like i was very
on the insides of things so like me and
the producers were the only ones that
knew things
some like the mafia yeah it was really
cool lie detectors are they real
you cannot film them so if you ever
watch them film that's bullshit oh nice
so you film like a b-roll of it okay
this happened to me dude where i went on
uh topher grace's podcast
and he it's like an adventure podcast
i've known him forever and he was like
oh you'll take a live doctor test and
it's based on heat and heart rate so if
someone asks you a question like he can
like there were a couple questions that
i was like you can't ask me that stuff
like about other comedians or like like
this comedian or is this comedian funny
and i like would get nervous
and then be like yes and it was like
it would come up as a lie and i was like
no i'm just nervous and embarrassed and
my body temperature's going up yeah
there's also ways you're not allowed to
ask questions as well so that's very
interesting like liking somebody isn't a
truth or like it has to be actual facts
so you were on 20th and 15th
at 2 p.m on a monday correct yes that's
a real question
yes or no pardon it has to be yes or no
yes but so you can't do your opinion on
a lie detector no that's bullshit huh
yeah the guy i worked with was uh he uh
that did that show he was a uh
uh
worked for the nypd as a detective and
he like he was very diligent about it
because his name was on the credits and
he did it for real
what did you like i'm obsessed with why
people are so funny
like or how that happened like you're so
naturally funny i think i have some
ideas why but like do you feel like
seeing
that like worst case scenario drama like
do you think that
helped hone your sense of humor or your
obliqueness or a cynicism or being able
to find com like humor and really dark
shit
yeah absolutely i mean but i mean i have
my own dark shit so like watching those
people i kind of felt bad for time to
time
were they getting paid
uh no they get a free trip to new york
in a hotel
one time one time they stole all the uh
all the uh blankets from the hotel like
the comforter and everything we were
like how'd you even get that out of
there
yeah
i had this one kid that came in and he
had like louis vuitton print tattooed
across his whole body and they did and
by the way the other thing is if you
ever notice on this
no no no no no but if you ever watch
those shows and notice that the people
are talking with lisps a lot that's
because they didn't have teeth before
the show and we sent them to a dentist
to put a bridge in
[Music]
so those people come in there with like
no teeth and they're like that was team
with my mom
it's crazy that's kind of a wild thing
to process i couldn't process that so
imagine not having teeth and then being
on tv with teeth within a half hour
dude that's a lot i used to be the
backstage guy so i had people like
throwing stilettos at me that were just
done and whatnot it was crazy let's see
what happens
facetiming a friend let's let's oh
dougie this will be something i don't
know we're going to facetime machine gun
kelly let's see
now you facetime see if he answers yours
no
rude you know what he did call me
yesterday and i didn't take the call i
was like why are you calling me uh tit
for chat if someone calls me and it's
not a facetime i assume it's a pocket
dial because my last name is my i'm
usually under whitney which is usually
the last in someone's like you know
thing coulson's so good to my kid my
kid's the biggest fan of him in the
world and colson like makes videos for
him also that is the sweetest yeah yeah
we went and saw you've seen him perform
yeah
dude i gotta be honest i had never seen
him live i did the movie with him he was
so funny it really pisses me off when
people that aren't comedians are funny
it just it's a little bit like like
athletes like blake griffin is hilarious
and you're who just got me bruce
springsteen is he funny hilarious i went
to his broadway show unbelievably funny
oh yeah yeah yeah i wouldn't saw that
i have a really hard time at broadway
shows because like one person unwrapping
something it's all i can't i get up i
get so mad like why do you have to have
your werther's original like now like
why are you like like
unwrap the butterscotch before you come
in it's bruce springsteen i haven't been
to a movie in years i can't like i
cannot go it's so disrespectful i think
it's because as a comic like being in
the i'm in the audience so rarely and
it's my nightmare that someone would be
a distraction or like make it about them
or you know ruin the show and there's it
has to be dead silent so i hear anything
and i'm like no bruce couldn't hear you
shut up yeah he started focused he
actually told people to shut up because
they were like screaming out like lyrics
or something and he was like stop that
why is he doing that what do you mean
why do you think he wants to do that
he's telling an amazing story i know
i've seen it but why why what's in it
for him because he loves performing and
he's an amazing artist i know but i'm
obsessed with people that have a lot
that are like ben stiller i'm always
like this kid just got in the olympics
like bruce has it all for what uh
something i know that they got into the
olympics okay bruce springsteen
congratulates jessica
on her equestrian team all right well
that's a bummer you don't find a lot of
people from the hood that you get to
join the equestrian team
that's a very
no tribe called equestrian dude yeah
it's uh
yeah if the horse does the work that's
the problem
oh you're you love animals yeah you
super love animals yeah it's it's just i
like competitive like jumping in the
olympics like you're flying a horse to
china like what are we doing i don't
like a lot of animals yeah tell me i
just don't like them i bet you a lot of
new yorkers it's weird like
andrew schultz is here a lot
and it's wild because new yorkers are on
one hand the bravest most teflon
uh
like badass people but then they're like
afraid of like a praying mantis i hang
out when i go do the miami improv with
the people that work at the miami improv
and they like to jump in lakes with
alligators and last time i did it and it
was a lot of fun it was really crazy did
you see anything
yes
yeah
there's this kid his name's stacks954
okay and
he he's awesome on instagram and he just
taunts alligators all day it's nuts
schultz knows him i called schultz about
him and schultz goes he just needs a
shot that's what shaw said about what is
it what is it stacks nine s-t-a-c-k-s z
come on he's from florida sorry nine
five seven nine five four nine five four
buddy okay
um uh taunts alligators that's a special
kind of mental illness yeah no he no no
he's just really his favorite person in
the world is stevo like he just wants to
be alright yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah okay
okay stephen is a friend of mine it's a
lot of the
the
surgeries are going to start soon i
imagine he gets a bunch of people just
sending him wild shit all the time still
the amount of icy hot that guy needs to
get through the day really like it's
just and he's sober yeah dude i mean
it's just like you can only get shot out
of a cannon a couple times before you're
like oh yeah my cartilage is gone yeah
you know but he's like the best dude
yeah he's he's also yeah he has new
teeth he just got new teeth
wow
i want new teeth yeah yeah i lick your
teeth i'll do it no your teeth are good
i wouldn't fuck with them really yeah
i don't know we'll see you have you ever
seen fake teeth that passed as real
teeth
yes they figured out tits they figured
out glass eyes
yes those are fake yes
but they're tough
not really they haven't figured it out
to the point it feels correct here's
what i'll say here's what i'll say i
don't know because it is very you know
like you can't punch yourself in the
face
yeah you can no you can't 1
i can punch no why not because i can't
okay but do it like not hard
i can easily punch myself if you can't
your your face will stop it unless
you're like a psychopath the the then
i'm a psychopath i can easily punch
myself in the face easily okay but
what have you done it what how do you
know have i inflicted pain on myself yes
yes no you can't like the same way that
you can't um tickle yourself you can't
tickle yourself you can't bite off your
own tongue there's like thumb thumb oh
tongue oh i just wanted to yeah you just
said you're you're
i like how much confidence that you have
sounded it sounded right it sounded
right and then i thought about people
like seizures and like like i was like i
don't know i feel like didn't don't a
lot of people choke on their own tongue
i don't have questions but no i thought
you can't punch yourself in the face
unless you're a psychopath so if you're
a psychopath if someone yawns and you
don't yawn that's one of the telltale
signs right wow yeah because it's like
yawning is contagious and it's like a
form of empathy you know when someone
yawns that means you're not a psychopath
like it's one of the like ways to find
it out
when you are not giving psychopaths like
i'm sorry who's dating more psychopaths
than me who knows more about psychopathy
i've been in hollywood for 15 years i
did it the old way okay okay i did it i
did it the old i think you should just
take a look at my friend's circle
i took notes from lawyers oh wow you
don't think i know about psychopaths but
yeah that's one of them and then i think
you can't punch yourself in the face
like hard
i know it's weird because as i'm saying
it i know a lot of people that like took
too many drugs and like stabbed
themselves in the chest but they were on
drugs i think if you're sober this is
also what i'm saying okay well those
people are boring we're both like none
of us have been sober ever so we don't
really know what that's like um but uh
but yeah that's something why did we get
to that
i'm obsessed with you your teeth i don't
think you should fuck with your teeth a
little bit of curcumin
oh yeah my tits
that's what it was when i touch them i
can't tell because i can feel these
little like um
like bags you know
like uh like what what is it like it's
like uh
you know those little things you put to
warm your hands like hand warmers yeah
like a little sack of sand i feel it
and sometimes i can see the little
puckers on the side that's always a
bummer when you can see the little
pucker on the side like a ziplock bag
like through the skin how did stand up
change for you with your tits
did you do it's a good question
yeah you did it yes i talked about it in
my third or i'm sorry my fourth special
i talked about the whole process and
like did jokes about it and stuff of
like how it happened and why i did it
and it hasn't really changed much like
i'll like joke about it sometimes and
but that's really it no i mean i don't
think that so i think it would be like
teeth
i know but teeth are like visible
nakedly okay i mean my life would change
if i was a topless performer
if that was my leading thing you know
female bert yeah you know
and uh that's really funny brat
um
if if he transitioned what it would be
um yeah there here's the deal
here's the deal with fake boobs versus
real boobs when you bend over they do
still get long and pointy okay they like
full traffic cone like that like traffic
cone that's been kicked in the side you
know like they do divot you know and you
know real boobs when you lay down they
disappear
yeah mine don't wow they go nowhere they
are like like an alligator coming out of
a pond okay it's just too it's
relentless they go nowhere the guy that
i'm dating he uh he had never been with
someone with fake poops and when i laid
down naked for he was like
like there was like a
oh
you're defying gravity
like it just was like uh it is weird
because nipples real nipples while
you're having they're not right here
they're out here yeah chilling like they
go
they take a break like i've done my job
uh your turn bitch and then uh but they
yeah they don't go anywhere which i kind
of missed that
i did like that
would you do anything else
i don't know i haven't been 50 yet i
haven't been 60 yet yeah and like the
technology like might get good i don't
know yeah that could be really scary
it's tricky though because like female
comedians don't have a great reputation
with plastic surgery
facts facts but that was back when they
were just you know what did bill burr
say for um he was like
the stapling legs here
[Music]
he's the goddamn best i love that man
more than anything what do you say about
he's like you just look like an old or a
young lizard what was it
because i think here's what really made
people look plastic surgery for a while
and i did this which was like lasers
they were like lasers that would like
burn the top layer your skin off and
then it would get rid of the hair on
your face which is what makes it so your
face isn't super shiny so when your face
is shiny you just like look like you've
had work done
i mean
but i would i'm not again like i'm not
against that shit like i think if people
want to get it like good for you if you
want to get a butt if you want to get
like i don't care like
i use that's what i should get it's just
a huge dumb
like you should have calf implants yeah
but yeah i like your teeth
you're too famous you can't do it now
it's i'm not famous but you don't like
yours i just i feel like you have such a
great smile oh thank you look how cute
come on don't i just feel like you know
what it was jennifer gray this is the
biggest cautionary tale remember
jennifer gray from dirty dancing nope
you're you're i'm in over my head wow
what hold on you know dirty dancing how
old are you can i ask 32 okay yeah i
mean you would know it with uh patrick
swayze yeah i know who he is you know
that oh yeah yeah yeah you've seen that
movie he kind of stole it for sure oh
it's his movie so i wasn't thinking
about that as matt fultron uh
hilarious comedian used to go on the
road with me a lot used to say on i know
him he's great the second patrick swayze
movie did not have patrick swayze in it
and he goes well as i say no swayze no
wayzi
[Laughter]
it is so fucking dumb but it just kills
me everyone's like what um but yeah so
that's him so jennifer gray she was the
girl in it she played baby and she had
this you know she has a
nose she has a prominent nose and then
she got super famous off this movie an
icon got a nose job and then her career
just it was over i like i found this out
not too long ago a lot of girls use
their bar mitzvah money to fix their
nose
i think that's really funny
makes me laugh how much that's a lot of
money yeah you can do anything you want
with it oh your parents make your way to
18 and then you get a nose job
my wife like knows numerous people and
my wife's yeah i think that's a pretty
i'm irish puerto rican my wife's jewish
my kids all three of those things and
he's uh
new york yeah just like perfect like
that i mean that's yeah to me i'm very
into ancestral trauma but also not
stereotyping you have to mix with blood
it's a tricky thing you have to mix the
blood yeah because you because like
mutts yeah yes it's always the best yeah
you can digest a lot of foods
um your kid will be able to yeah because
that's kind of the main thing do you
have allergies
i just got them in my 30s yeah yeah so
fucking annoying what are they
just like runny nose and then the back
of my head
yeah oh yeah i had to take a test
because it was getting so bad i'm
allergic to all grass all of it you know
what i'm starting to think this is a
scam because i went and got the allergy
test and they put like 40 needles in you
like on your back or something right and
they put these needles in your skin and
they're like it's red it's like yeah
there's a needle in my skin like they do
the scratch test i'm just allergic to
needles you fucking ass you know what
i'm saying it's like yeah you poked me
with a needle you dick but they told me
absolutely cantaloupe grass
like all of it like i'm like all of it
all of it's bad for me yeah and dust i'm
like okay well yeah it does up there so
it's a wrap yeah like what do you mean
don't we have like bugs in our eyeballs
our eyebrows we had to we had to we had
to run away to um uh florida last year
during pandemic um because the bottom of
my building got looted in new york city
and i had a kid and i got scared and i
was like we need to be out and we went
down to florida and like daily i thought
i had copied because of my allergies wow
yeah
renowned hershberg has such a funny
thing about covet it was like it was
just like just perfectly put because a
lot of people that had coveted um why it
was such a mind fuck is you can have no
symptoms so he'd be like i'd wake up
every morning and be like i feel great
it's probably going
just like if you're sick you think you
have it if you're not sick you think you
have it well for the first month i
played like am i hungover or is this
covet
it's probably about it yeah what did i
do while i was drunk last night did i
socialize when i was on me let me just
assuming making mistakes still let me
say it again making mistakes while
zooming and drunk oh i ruined a very
good friend of mine's funeral
what zoo memorial
wow
it was bad
well i have did they even give you a uh
what's it called i went to a wedding
where they didn't show everybody that
was there i mean
look i didn't give them a ton of choice
but yeah they should have muted me or
taken me out so you're just like back
and then you're just like how did it go
bad like what did you do
like what's the deal with men
um it was you brought andrew schultz
look at my heavies like at a funeral
basically i had kovid and did you have
it no no no no i got it real bad i was
in a coven like fog for a good month and
a half two months like i could not
couldn't like tell him once i got
canceled i'll start saying i did and i
was in the pop
i was in the fog
for a year i'm telling you i started
thinking i was just going crazy i got
really paranoid because the losing the
taste and smell that is brain damage
that is damage to your brain yeah that's
why i'm like very against it what are
the other things that are being damaged
yeah my memory took how many vaccines do
you have i was like dude
one a day
i just put a chip in my arm every
morning no we did my cell phone's been
working so much better since i got the
first
since i got the third my cell phone is
awesome if we did i can never have a
child but uh we did the johnson and
johnson but it was very sketchy because
it was like they were like if you do
fight we can only give you shots if you
come with a group of
five people it was like a bringer show
for vaccines
no yes i was like hey do you want to get
the vaccine people like what i was like
we have to go to today if i need two
more people yeah i don't like that it's
like a very weird business and then they
gave us the card it was like on a
post-it note i was like this doesn't
feel
i went to like the nicest situation of
all time but they needed more velezes
so like once i put my name in they put
me to the upper east side and like they
like shooed me and they're like yes mr
velez
please come get a shot is this to try to
just get the stats less racist yep
it actually said no walk-ins on the
hospital so you and i watched like
puerto rican privilege yeah i used my
puerto rican privilege it's very it
comes in very very rarely very rarely
but when it shows up it really is great
yeah yeah like in pandemics only
that's stressful yeah but i was like i
couldn't remember stuff i was like i
would remember that movie memento like i
had no i love that movie i had no
short-term memory like so i would walk
in a room be like why am i in here and
it's tricky because i am a little bit
like ditzy
anyway so it was like it was
just enough more of like an
airheadedness that made it seem like i'm
just like on
cocaine or something you know like just
felt like it was like bad yeah it was
really bad how long did it take
um i got in the car with grace and we
were on the freeway and i was driving 10
miles an hour on the freeway because i
thought the cars were so much closer to
me than they were like i was having
trouble like ascertaining like spatial
differences essentially and i was like i
had to pull over and i was like i
couldn't drive for like a month it went
on for like a month and a half
wow that's really scary it's pretty well
there's still some things that i'm like
what was that girl's name that i was
like best friends with in high school
and like takes me a second
yeah but i have that as well yeah that's
just getting older it's hard to tell or
i just don't care
you know my brain is starting to just
prioritize what actually kind of matters
like we
our thing is that deep cut like remember
that thing no one else remembers like
pulling that like jamiroquai reference
you know what i'm saying we gotta like
pull
deep references most of my set is
jamerrickwise
that's what you are the jamiroquai of
comedy i mean
i've been saying that for a while can
you pull him up because i have no clue
who you're talking about i don't want to
fuck up my algorithm
you don't know jamiroquai well give me
the song what's the song virtual
insanity was the name of the song you
don't remember this that's the name of
your tell me that's the name of your
kovit fog the name of my the documentary
about my life um
uh
that's so interesting next you're going
to tell them i'm really bad with names
terrible books with the lid off
i hate this
i don't know what you want from me i
don't know if this is making me it's not
making me feel old it's making me just
feel
far away from you i like 50 cent a lot
oh by the way 50 cent
no one is a funnier troll than 50 cents
he's incredible
that's queens that's reading a book
taunting floyd mayweather was one of the
funniest things i've ever seen in my
life the memes he would put up of was it
lala kent is her name and the guy the
roland not roland emmerich randall
randall emmerich no randall
i mean he's known in hollywood as like
one of the biggest douchebag like tool
assholes and like he does happen to have
one lie that like one eyeball that's
like a little lazy and he would put like
gollum up and like he would just put the
most
disrespectful shit
he was so disrespectful when he came out
i was in the seventh grade when in the
club came out and i'm not kidding you ja
rule went to my middle school
oh that song was we
we
turned on ja rule his own middle school
turned on ja rule it was sad
it was silly like clowned him in
something he was just
he tore apart murder inc
50 cent tore apart murdering he's been
shot 12 times a lot is he more
more than you should shoot me
i know it's fine have you met him yes
not as tall as you think he is
name's curtis but at the same time he's
like he's yes he's he's popping
through
yeah yeah i'm obsessed with him i'm
obsessed with every emmy season that
comes around he goes nuts that his show
isn't nominated for an emmy he has like
five shows
but he what's the one that um he's just
doing bmw
what power power he like goes off on why
isn't power nominated
yeah i understand that it's so funny
they they they don't want him
yeah he's a troll vitamin water vitamin
water he's also healthy as shit yeah
invested in vitamin water he's so cool
he's possibly my biggest hero really
yeah growing up you met him i met him
one time after when i was uh
correspondent on the nightly show yeah
and uh i just walked into his green room
and i was like hey man i'm from queen's
village and he was like oh so sad and i
was like yeah not like that but um
you're i love
you he was like somebody was very
nervous to meet because i love him so
much he's really the man also like just
a very nice dude also that song it's so
funny because this is embarrassing to
say but i
like every couple months when i'm like
need to like
jazz up my exercise like situation i'll
make like a like a like a playlist
that's like you're like a 50 cent
running mix or your like workout mix
it's the most embarrassing songs but
dude in the club's always in there it's
easily
in the club like
these are all songs that i remember
where i was when they came out and by
the way songs it usually takes me a
couple times to get into a song like the
first time you hear it it's already your
favorite song yeah and has not i mean
there's a couple like um uh i had like
crimea river doesn't differ and i was
like
i remember loving this song but it's not
dude when in the club comes out it's
like wow it's almost like um uh uh
journey separate ways or i think it's
gonna be in that kind of hall of fame or
uh what's the one that uh bon jovi the
one that everyone in boston loves so
much lebanon yeah you know when like
that shit comes on the wedding and
everyone's like wow yeah let's cheat on
each other oh yeah i don't i had cypher
sounds dj my wedding it was different
okay yeah
let me ask you so uh what
what influ has did rap have an influence
on you being a comedian yes and actually
i you know kind of worked against me but
at the same time was for it how's that
uh because i moved like that for a long
time
until like i like learned humility and
learned to calm down yeah interesting
yeah because i do look at guy for a long
time i looked at comedy as like a
competition
interesting yeah the battle yes
i don't think that's
i like i used to walk around just being
like i don't want them to remember your
name when i come off stage
like if me and you were on a show
together so i would do yeah
people will remember yeah
but i just like that's how i used to do
stand up right it's like it's something
that serves you really well where you're
on stage but the second you get off you
gotta drop it it's like it's tricky
because when i didn't for a long time oh
interesting like off stage like the way
that you
you know
i don't know it's like that's why i hit
it off with like schultz and that's why
i hit it off with certain guys but then
in other ways it was way too aggressive
yeah it's like the thing of like you
know the thing about rappers everyone's
like i'm number one it's like well
someone's got to be number two like if
you're how are you all number one like i
want the rapper that's just like i'm
number four but like i'll be number one
next month like i've got this bank i've
got a banker coming out next year then
it'll probably be jay-z let's be honest
and then probably kanye yay i don't know
um like it'll rotate who's the best i
mean that's the same thing with kanye's
the best who kanye yeah ever yeah
i think he's like the prince of our
generation i don't think we'll see
anything like that ever again yeah yeah
people are gonna love him when he's dead
yes
how's he gonna die i don't wanna know
actually i really but it bums me out and
it really bums me out that people
continue to kind of uh uh uh attack him
i think it's really crazy he's
numerous times has told us he's mentally
ill
mentally ill and people continue to go
after him the other day he shaved his
head in different places and everybody's
tearing them apart it's like yeah we
know why why are we still going after
him it's weird yeah i think it's weird
that mental illness is open game
comedians like we've managed to just
talk about our mental illnesses uh in
the form of podcasts and like make it a
big stand up yeah yeah but it's just
sort of like tricky because i always
forget how taboo it is to admit you have
some kind of mental illness it seems
weak it's bitch whereas like in comedy
it's like you're rewarded for it talking
about it well i think that's the coolest
thing kanye's ever said where he's like
he's like i it was something like i am
bipolar and it's awesome and i just
think that's really cool
i think that's just a cool way to look
at it yeah it's like a superpower you
can be a bunch of different people
so wild yeah yeah it's funny i mean i
was who was it it was like i was dealing
with like a family member who was like i
have multiple personalities sword i was
like why aren't any of them cool none of
them like five said like none of them
are chill like kid like none of them
they all suck like that doesn't that's
that feels like a choice like i can't
help it
um but uh yeah that's hard but i i'm
fascinated because like growing up the
way that i kind of like got into comedy
really is i wanted to make documentaries
and i was filming
i would go uh into the bronx and i would
film female breakdancers i was making a
documentary on female breakdancing this
is amazing
they were all dressed like you today
and um but to me it was always like that
getting that reaction like to like
watching brave dancers like do something
crazy and i was like ah like that's what
you're going for in comedy they're like
what like that big surprise moment you
know and uh and it's also like a very
confrontation art
confrontation and then and obviously
they're being like you know a lot of
like
shows and music around there was like a
lot of rap you're like that's a joke
that's a straight-up great roast joke oh
yeah no rappers are incredible punch
lines it's comedy punch lines that rhyme
they are they're punch we don't have to
rhyme when we do it little wayne is
incredible at punchlines like like every
time you hear it you hear a new level of
the joke or a new meaning of the joke
you're like oh shit like every time i
hear this i hear a different thing
why do you think uh mental illness like
runs rampant in comedy
a lot of things i think that that's a
tricky that's a tricky one um i think
that mental illness in general is uh
more rampant than we think or know or
ever understand especially addiction um
i think addiction is we only really pay
attention to it when it's like
completely unmanageable like makes the
news or is a negative addiction i think
things that are
uh
ostensibly like positive attributes a
lot of work addiction like a lot of the
most successful people you see like
that's why i get obsessed when i see
someone that's like
really really rich and really famous and
at 50 at 60. i'm like why are you still
doing it is this even about it at this
point like why wouldn't you want you
know is this an addiction is it because
addiction is defined as um
essentially to continue doing something
despite negative consequences or it's
like when it's no longer a choice when
you want to stop it you just like can't
because you need to do it for your ego
for your dopamine receptors for anything
you know i think that comedians we just
tend to share we advertise our mental
illness more than other people do um you
know that part of our disease is like
everyone needs to know everything all
the time um but uh from what i
understand like i know i know plenty of
people that are
you know didn't come from trauma they
might have some kind of like ancestral
trauma going on um but i think for the
most part like not being seen hurt or
understood is the main trauma you know
and like from mine i mean growing up in
alcoholic home many people have grown up
in alcohol calm my i
i
don't want to brag but i was not planned
um
uh
parents are too drunk to remember to
abort me
um but i
plenty of people have come come from
that right and then essentially the
thing that i believe led me into
comedies i was actually more neglected
than anything i was alone a lot and i
had like wrote in journals and i would
interview myself like i would interview
that's how like okay lonely and sad and
bored and i still do have i let you get
a word in edgewise no no no this is
great by the way you know that i'm
obsessed when people interview
themselves where they go like was i
happy about it absolutely
do i want to do it again maybe but it's
like no one asked you that like you're
literally just interviewing yourself
um but uh i think for me i
i i think when you grow up in alcoholic
home or there's a lot of borderline
personality disorder my home there was a
lot of just like emotional chaos and
right so if you were fine you just
weren't a problem you know but if you
did have some kind of needs you were
generally mocked and like oh what you're
hungry like okay
like you know what i mean it was like
you were rewarded for having very little
needs and it wasn't worth engaging with
the drunk uh
driven adults because it just there was
going to be too histrionic of a reaction
and you would get like sort of punished
so you like learn to kind of do things
on your own so i you know being a
comedian it's not just about what you
write and what you do when you're on
stage you have a very high tolerance for
being able to be alone we're alone a lot
i mean you're married and you have a kid
but like you're on the road and you're
in hotels and like a lot i've made a lot
of moves not to be alone yeah yeah i
bring a lot of people with me i'm uh
yeah no you don't stay in hotels
interesting like yeah oh wow yeah yeah
i don't like like even here i'm i'm i'm
i'm in a house well see that's really
healthy and smart i mean for me like i
just have a very low tolerance for
socializing like i can't do it all the
time like i just can't do it it doesn't
um i think this is a lot of people
confuse introvert and extrovert i always
thought it just meant like someone that
loves socializing and someone that likes
being alone it's actually whether you
derive energy from being alone or drive
energy from being around people so i and
this isn't negative to any of the people
around me but it does
deplete me to hang out with people
oh no oh okay in a good way yes yes
that's what i feel for four hours i'll
go home and i'm like oh that was so fun
i had the best time like now i need to
go to sleep i'm not like yeah dude let's
do five more hours like i unless like
drugs are involved or something but it
it a lot of people like my friend dory
she will
literally like go to a drinks at five
another drinks at 6 30 and they're like
let's do this wine tasting i'm like i
don't she's just like inexhaustible i
have that problem here really hard like
because i won't don't make plans and
that's why i love new york so much but
la i can't just be like i'm gonna go do
this it has to be planned out and i
don't have time for that yeah exactly i
don't have time and i'm just really bad
at plants that's it well you're probably
just like so
the grooves in your brain are so used to
being able to go like dude 20 minutes
one of me you know what i'm saying
or like i'm uptown where are you like
it's just a different thing it's tough
here yeah you can't just like on the
drop of a dime you know it's like
someone's like you want to hang out
you're like
let me leave venice
uh i gotta stop and let my dog i can be
there yeah yeah if you have dogs here
like they can stay yeah
if you have an animal here it can die
but before you get home
why are you doing that because we're
we're slow like
smoothly transitioning
uh we're going from this incredible
effervescent
discussion
with rick with ricky velez i don't want
it to stop either i know but
you know absence makes the heart grow
fonder we're going to get right back
because nothing is more important
than putting the right food in your
gullet
and that's why we're here to talk to you
about green chef and look
i i really admire that green chef uh
wants to be involved in our show and
have someone who famously starved
themselves for 10 years i think it makes
sense we're all models we're all uh
athletes we're all we are we're all
stunning we all eat yeah all of us eat
and here's what i'll say i am now at a
place where i have such a positive
relationship with food because i underst
i don't think of it as food i think of
it as
fuel correct
i think of it as fun
um
think of it as foreplay
nothing is more important than what you
put in your body brain food i sometimes
want to try all plant-powered but to go
through the grocery store yourself is
it's like impossible you're never gonna
get it right like i need someone that's
gonna curate it perfectly send it to my
door is there by any chance a company
that could do this green chef has a meal
plan for every healthy lifestyle keto
paleo plant-powered diet or even if you
just want to have delicious but balanced
dishes green chefs expert chefs curate
every recipe and with over 30 meal
choices every week and the flexibility
to switch plans you'll never have to
sacrifice taste for nutrition you can
enjoy restaurant quality dishes in the
comfort of your own home oh that is like
a miracle a dream i just got my first
green chef box and i loved it so go to
greenchef.com good for you one two five
and use code good for you one two five
to get 125 off including free shipping
that's screen chef dot com slash good
for you one two five and use code good
for you one two five to get a hundred
and twenty five dollars off including
free shipping hold on was was good for
you one taken
no it's 125 oh
the number one meal kid for eating well
because we all need brain food
because we all have low blood sugar
um
trust us
or else we now
segue from
food that is a good choice
to the reason you can't afford it
to the reason you student loans so the
reason you need the promo code you're
tired of eating ramen
ernest was voted best student loan
refinancing overall by nerd wallet
ernest has some of the lowest rates
flexible payments and an in-house team
ready to help because let's be honest
your student loans are a nightmare you
can't do it on your own it's too
emotional it's too triggering it's too
angering you need someone that's just
gonna like very calmly be like this is
what we're gonna do we're gonna
refinance and like you're gonna be okay
under control because i find that like
when i had really bad loans before i
paid them off i was too embarrassed to
even tell people about it much less ask
for help and you can't return your
college education i tried yeah i tried
to get mine back for cash with earnings
i was like never used great condition
with earnest you could change your
interest rate get a lower monthly
payment and you never pay fees not even
late fees with earnest it only takes two
minutes to see what your new rate could
be and there's no credit impact and
right now ernest is offering our
listeners a hundred dollar cash bonus
refinance your student debt at
earnest.com whitney not available in all
states once again you get a 100 cash
bonus when you visit earnest.com whitney
to refinance your student loan visit
earnest.com whitney for more details not
available in all states terms and
conditions apply earn a student loan
refinancing made by earnest operations
llc nmls number 120 4917 california
financing law license number
6054788 535 mission street san francisco
california
94105 visit earnest.com
licenses for a full list of licenses if
you're the kind of person that just
really loves to read about licenses god
speeds speaking of san francisco we're
going to be in san francisco soon doing
stand-up comedy so if you have
loans and you have debt and you're
stressed get earnest and then also come
yuck it up for a little bit yeah laugh
with us laughter is the best medicine
touch me too
no prozac is but um we are going to 30
cities guys before we get back to ricky
velez just a reminder go to
whitneycomics.com we're going to
tennessee we're coming to virginia
virginia canada canada we're going to
you need to get your passport have you
gotten your passport yet no i've only
been here a day and a half it's i'm
sorry
we're
have not been gone how have we been gone
we haven't yet we've been going okay i
don't i don't have a grace i have to do
it on my own okay okay you have time to
get your hair colored and cut no i
haven't
this is titillating for the listener
slash viewer so go to whitneycomings.com
we are coming to 40 cities so you guys
get your tickets now a lot of shows are
sold out we're going to be adding second
shows uh we are touring until next april
this will be the last time i tour for a
long time because i'm pretty sure that
i'm doing this tour uh at the expense of
my ability to have biological children
so come see us now it's an amazing show
you never know what's gonna happen we
had katie thirst in the bachelorette pop
in on the anaheim show last week we have
people pop in benton's talking to the
audience taking your questions emily's
just living her truth
and uh i love you guys and now back to
the brilliant ricky velez and me being
super weird and awkward with him because
i just loved him so much that i started
getting overwhelmed i wonder if this is
the point yet in the podcast where he
goes you're intense that's towards the
end if not tune in and see what he says
stick around
that's really fascinating and then i
think i
i anytime i would um
yeah be heard i felt like i could never
make my point and i also my reality was
denied a lot and i think like you're
fine you're not hungry you i need to pee
no you don't you're fine i'm hungry no
you're not you just ate like i i think
we don't and i'm the only reason i'm
being this boring about this is because
i don't have the bond to born at all
because
we do where you're you know trying to
ride the line between being a good
parent that lets the child have a
healthy amount of adversity and like be
able to you know um not be too coddled
but also not be dismissive of a you know
and i got a lot of dismissive stuff so
my i was like wait no but i am hungry or
like no i am cold no you're not you're
fine but i'm cold like they just told me
i'm not and then children can't
understand they can't fathom the idea
that their parents have flaws so they
have to yeah no you don't i didn't
realize for a very long time well into
my twenties it's too psychologically
disorganized yeah i think oh my my he's
always been right yeah exactly like that
they can't be drunk driving me around
like you have to go like well i'm just
crazy you know or i'm just insane or i'm
just emotional i'm just sensitive or i'm
just you know difficult or whatever and
then um
and then so i
comedy for me i think the what
drove me to it was when you say
you know
whatever i
cheat whatever i cheated on someone i
don't know why this joke is coming to me
i haven't i've i don't even remember the
joke but um and um when i cheated i used
to program
guys in my phone in as other things so
that i wouldn't get caught and then my
boy like why is bank of america calling
you at two in the morning you know like
and then people laugh and you're like
everyone's done that everyone and then
laughing is saying we get you we heard
what you said yes we either relate to it
or we
you know like i'm doing a joke right now
but like the toys we played with his
kids like we used to play bloody
knuckles and people go i'm like
it's really just people going got it
heard you instead of you're crazy
and no you're not yeah it makes you not
feel alone yeah no it makes you not feel
alone it just made me feel like it's
funny there's a good chunk of my uh
special that's about getting beat as a
kid yes and it's just like
that that was possibly the first time
like when i started doing that joke
where i was like oh look it's not me
it's not just me i'm not bad it's just
this whole generation didn't have well i
had to learn that with my kid and you if
you ever have a kid it's very wild to
start
once you're seeing him grow up and
you're at his age you start remembering
the things that happened to you during
that time that's my therapist said it
happens all the time
tina fey talked about this i think in
some article or maybe it was her book
which was incredible um
where she you know what happened with
her the scar on her face was basically
she was playing outside and a dog right
no it was a ma of man on meth with an oh
cut her she said it was a dog for a long
time though yes am i right emily was a
guy with it
yeah but she doesn't talk about it
because it makes her parents so sad so
like yeah she she didn't admit what it
was for a long time but it was a psycho
person it's like a like a
something came up with a knife cut her
face when she was five years old and
basically a therapist said to her like
when your daughter turns five you might
just lose your mind
because that's the age it happened to
you at and you might just go crazy at
like exactly what you're saying it was
interesting my kid was doing something
that was upsetting me for a long time
and not a long time he did it for like a
week and i like had to be told that like
kids aren't born bad this is just
something small he's doing right now
and it's because for so long i thought i
was just born bad
because you get told you're bad
enough you start to believe it and i
believed it way until into my 20s
it was really crazy do you forgive your
parents
um
i pity my father i forgive my mother and
i think my mother was just protecting me
have you ever done any like ancestral
stuff like what like basically like i i
just i had such a hard time like
forgiving you know there's like sexual
abuse in my face i mean stuff that
you're just like
it's you can't forgive and she i i
shouldn't be forgiven i needed to figure
out how to i had so much addiction but i
also had in my families on both sides
and then i also had like uncles that
went to jail like regularly so
i didn't like
i didn't understand that and i used to
say my uncle had pit bull reactions
and now that i'm older i look at it and
i go oh no that was somebody that just
had no clue how to deal with his
emotions sure yeah and because to me
it's like i mean i'm in a 12-step
program called al-anon it's basically um
if you were raised by alcoholics it's
like adult children about it sounds like
it's missing the cue
what is
and it's um or aca which is the the
substrate of it is like adult children
of alcoholics which basically was like
you grew up in alcoholic home you had
your reality denied you have an
overdeveloped sense of responsibility
you internalize the consequences for
their behavior you spend a lot of time
protecting their behavior uh your
biggest fear is embarrassment that's the
other thing like the older i get the
more i realize like
embarrassment is my main thing and
you know they say that comedians we
become comedians to control how we're
embarrassed because it's imminent and
like i'm going to make fun of myself
before my last time is coming so like
get fuck outta here like i had to defend
myself at a very young age about that
kind of stuff but i think it was more
like you know to me i was so embarrassed
all the time when you have like
alcoholic family members like doing
crazy shit or screaming and neighbors
come over like you haven't paid the
tuition and i would come home with like
um bill's safety pin to my chest i
couldn't go on the field trips because
the form wasn't signed i was the kid
that i'd just like stay at school you
know i don't know if mine was that far
though
like i just mean in general like
embarrassment like i gotta figure out a
way but and then any of this stuff like
with aca perfectionism and um uh
gravitating towards people that need to
be pity to rescue like dating people
that are like i can't read like i don't
have time for the shit like you know
what i mean like it just
feels like i can't read by the way
i very much can't read
that's amazing
i don't have time for this bullshit
i don't have time to teach a grown man
how to read yeah oh you just he didn't
learn it's not a mental disorder
no he just like he was like yeah just on
drugs or something
i fell in love with the fact that this
person needed a lot because my
self-esteem was so low that the only way
i could drive any self-worth was to
caretake an adult who actually just
needed to be taught how to fish not
enabled
you know what i'm saying or like
gravitating towards drug addicts and
stuff because that's what i grew up
around like like trying to keep people
alive like at what point and like did
you start figuring all this out um i
both my parents had strokes uh at this
in the same year uh and i had a family
member going to rehab and then as that
was all happening i was like going to
the rehab every day and like bringing
food and bringing sweaters and stuff and
uh essentially the therapist like you
can't come here anymore because you're
you're hurting this person because
you're solving all the problems for them
so that they're not gonna develop the
pride and the you know you have to give
them the dignity of their own experience
like this is part of the problem this
person needs to like learn how to be an
adult and you're infantilizing them by
trying to fix them and caretake them so
your addiction is actually caretaking
people that you think need your help but
your help is actually hurting them and
stunting them
oh wow and then
your vocabulary is incredible
really yeah i feel like i'm really out
of it and like stuttery and odd i'm
still hungover from
a coulson baker
he's extravaganza you we had the best
weekend ever by the way once we
had misspeaks
we went we all went to uh denver
together to do comedy works and we
actually made him do five minutes
dude he's so funny he killed
he's absolutely killed will he do his um
let's see if he'll do his
all right this guy tells me that you are
hilarious in denver
hey buddy
oh my god what's up dog i love that you
don't have a shirt on
you're the best
how are y'all living
uh what's something what's one of the
jokes that you did in denver
i was telling them about how you killed
in denver dog oh my god my stand up set
um
see
you said some really funny shit last
night actually he was like killing it
was really annoying have you seen ricky
special has he seen your special no but
closely
dude it is ridiculous does he know that
coulson i didn't tell you this
was why the fuck does this person keep
calling me i didn't know my homies was
at your was at your special dude i close
i closed with uh your song by the way i
bought it and i didn't tell you yeah i
didn't tell you i want to do just the
same one of his songs
um
because judd apatow's a great man
dude have you heard the story about the
drug dealer in the ocean
no have you heard the story of the have
you heard the ugly baby joke from ricky
there's a few of them yeah
there's a lot of them
dude he talks about we have beautiful
kids where did you go on vacation
dominican republic in the dominican
republic like drug dealers they're not
allowed to be on the beach so they just
wait in the ocean and then he went
swimming in the ocean and this drug
dealer swims up to him and he's like yo
dude colson it ends with uh play this
when i'm gone
oh whoa crazy yeah wow and then my kid
comes out and jams out on the guitar
it's sick
oh my god yo his kid is so such a g i
know we face time with him earlier he
misses you i feel bad yeah i'm going
back to new york are you here are you in
l.a you're in l.a what's the record it's
good you guys can't be two good fathers
you like
you know you got to give your kid a
little adversity so they're successful
everybody keeps saying this and
everybody's like oh don't you want your
kid to be broke like you no no bro i
want him to like just chill live his
life a bit dead be like a little dead
beast no he has a little smidge in a
deadbeat my kid has a stock portfolio
his life is sick
he's gonna be a nerd dude your kid's
gonna be a nerd stop loving himself i
couldn't read yeah i did
whitney doesn't fuck with men that can't
read i don't know all right dude i love
you guys have a fucking go are you guys
about to do it obviously you guys aren't
just hanging out in front of the podcast
i'm in town for another day and then i'm
out back to new york i don't hang out
with people unless it's monetized
[Music]
we love you
he's just so cool he's he's literally
the coolest guy always been the coolest
guy and he's always like he's the
realest too
don't
piss him off
like i don't know him like that like
i've never seen any of that there is a
music video that he recently did that he
gets into a fist fight in
and they taped it as a real fist fight
what don't he did a full
full music video in the beginning of the
music video he gets into a fist fight
and they actually taped a fist fight
like coulson walks out and just starts
scrapping with a guy that maybe what
happened with conor mcgregor was that
for real i don't know i saw closing that
night and he didn't even mention it it's
wild because i was like that like i
think connor knows what he's doing
always i mean this is all for show a lot
of it has to be for show yeah that's
what i was thinking yeah it's like now
he's like full wwe he's like the number
one punk emo
star right now like why won't you pick a
fight with him he's in the tabloids all
the time connor needs to stay in it
that's really smart yeah yeah but it's
also like i it was weird because
kel's i call him kells i don't know what
is his name coulson i know that's his
name but kel's is what everyone called
him on the movie so that got in my head
oh god i don't want to be like me and
kel's like i don't want to be a nerd
carlson i'm already wearing a young
hip-hop you look awesome
scuba suit
um pre-owned by who like what is tyga i
don't even know what this is who made
this tyga
um he's in trouble he's in trouble oh
well okay
fine now for making that shirt okay yeah
exactly fine fine even better um i
just we should make a super group of
like tiger chet hanks and soulja boy
tower
isn't he soldier i tell him yeah isn't
it the full thing or draco yeah this is
what drives me a little bit insane with
people that push back on saying they and
them you're willing to call
soulja boy tell them
you'll change what prince is like i want
my name to be the artist's formula knows
prince we're like no problem i'll say a
full sentence for you
no pushback at all john cougar
mellencamp changed his name how many
times
remember
john cougar melanchol he's cougar and
then he was john mellencam there's john
cougar mellencamp
uh
if you're a woman and you um
you don't have to change your name to
that just when you turn 40 they just
start calling you cougar anyway and then
who else uh drake was aubrey
yeah no problem no questions asked and
then it's like can you just i think we
need to stop outsourcing our talent
two no more canadians
really
i mean english people really take some
shit over no the canadians have taken
everything really yeah and australians
oh fever who bieber oh drake yep um
i do really like those milk boys though
i think they're funny i still don't
understand milk
that's tim dillon is that the guy that
want to go on a date with me yeah which
one is that tim dillon want to go on a
date with you you flipped them no
the reality is tim dillon and i we will
end up doing a murder suicide together
in a hotel room oh jesus christ like
that's absolutely we're both just going
to
um kill each other uh like we do have
like an arrangement like that it's like
most people are like let's just if i
like tim if you and i if we don't find
anyone by 45 let's just be together
we're like if we don't find someone by
45 let's just kill kill ourselves
together just like a non-sexual
relationship just hanging out yeah tim
like basically was like here like the
whole pandemic we were like fucking
sorry this is a sick place to start like
on some like gray garden shit yeah like
all that stuff that he was shooting at
the pandemic was here and he would i
would walk outside and he was like
shooting his ads in the pool
and he filled the pool up with magic
spoon cereal which is delicious we love
it but i don't need it all over the i
had a rat a rat in the coyote problem i
was like dude like but um uh yeah tim is
a legend of all legends he's uh he's a
character i just love him so much oh
yeah and anyway so we were with him in
austin we went to do rogan and austin he
came on and he was saying that the one
of the knelt guys wants to date me but i
don't know what nelk is aren't they very
send it's
i've actually researched them because i
was researching like that gig economy
and no it's not music it's just a bunch
of like frat kids that kind of do like
their own like vlogs okay and um
i mean they're completely wildly
inappropriate but at the same time they
like they're taking over you know who
else needs to join our band who's that
jamiroquai
who's that
oh i know now
by the way oh shit that's what i wanted
to ask about you don't remember this
no
oh i do yes i do super corny this was
like trl yeah it was like it was very
mtv jams yeah you know and he was very
like i can't explain it like what did
you want to ask kells about jamiroquai
he knows because he's in music i know
but i mean that's like asking me about a
comedian no i'm not in music yeah but
like you came up on music yeah not that
you can music people can know community
i just feel like you've been heavily
influenced by music and a lot of
a lot of comedians can be heavily
influenced by music like andrew schultz
as well like i went and i was with him
what's his music i mean no i mean when i
went to um when he was doing that
netflix special about the turn your
phone and him doing yeah yeah yeah i was
with him and i was like just like sort
of helping pitch ideas and stuff and i
was with him in new york and i was like
this is like rap and he's like yeah
that's the whole thing and i was like oh
i just got that
now i like i see what
is for it to be so funny that it's a
stand-up joke because there's no
audience like i see what you're doing
and it's just he's so heavily i think
he's been more influenced by rappers
than comedians
and i think a lot of comedians i'm sorry
uh rappers are influenced by comedians i
agree you know
but the the the those elk boys they love
comics like even one of them yesterday
posted up uh what are their names uh
there's one guy that goes by steve will
do it
is that him that's who likes you jesse
oh steve will do it loves you he's sick
it's the muscular guy yeah steve yeah
he's got three thousand followers that
can't be him that's not him no no no uh
that's
aren't they always like giving teslas to
people uh
i'll i don't like teslas if he can let
me find him hook me up with a different
one if he can give me a corolla yeah if
we if we could get emily
so this is the thing like they like take
like look at his picture it's him and
trump like they love trolling they truly
no they're they troll they troll they
they they've gone after youtube before
because they got taken out of algorithms
they get like they're
they're really wild
okay we did have a exchange
well you've had an exchange with him yes
can we publicize it you well no he
basically mentioned me in one of his
stories and i just wrote back ha
oh i don't know what that is you should
say i heard you have a crush
should i just send the eggplant emoji
you're out of the game what the fuck do
you know dude what do you mean how long
have you been you've been married for a
minute i've been to with my uh wife for
10 years that is sick you guys are uh
and let me ask you
how did the pandemic affect your
relationship positive negative positive
oh yeah i know a lot of people
a lot of people broke up it was like as
soon as that was scary that was really
scary because that happened like in
three months there were so many people
just willing to throw in the towels yeah
it was like turns out like the only
reason this works is because i was gone
eight hours today yeah yeah you know i'm
saying this works for traveling exactly
and like cheating you couldn't cheat no
it made me just it was cool actually
because the the first year we had our
kid i didn't get to do the summer with
him because of king of staten island
because i was i was legitimately in and
out of like back and forth staten island
with judd and i had to write and work
that much yeah so when pandemic happened
i got to like make up all this time i
had lost and yeah and then i feel like a
lot of people like we fell in love
because they're like oh shit you're dope
i forgot about that was cool because
like we got rid of nannies we did it and
it was just us and it was really cool
and
why the delay in getting married why
it's seven years in um we got married
once we found out we were having a kid
but at the same time we had already had
this discussion i was looking at rings
already
rings yes
were you like alone looking at rings i'm
just kind of obsessed with this whole
process yes yeah yeah i actually there's
a girl that's related to a jeweler at
the comedy cellar and she helped me out
with the whole entire thing i'm obsessed
with the fact that
it's so wild i'm obsessed with the fact
that guys
get to all be like in a jewel heist for
like a couple weeks i used to stay up at
night and play video games with the
rings sitting in front of me while she
was sleeping like for like a week while
i had it it was really crazy you want to
hear how i did it yeah yes because i
just love that like guys like they
there's like i had to hide it here and
i'd hide it here and they're just like
smuggling jewels around
my wife does not look through things
like that i just had it in the draw
um
but my wife checks all my receipts
because i don't care i'll just pay for
things like i i i don't look and she
always checks my receipts and she always
finds shit and then i had them write in
the receipt will you marry me
and she
looked at the receipt and she goes we
got somebody else's bill oh honey and i
was like no that's yours
and then when it was on the table by the
time she was done looking at the bill
wait she was
she was looking to like to see don't
have the belt it's like if there are
errors yeah
which happen a lot more than you think
can i tell you something especially at
hotels here's what here's what's fucked
up i hate going through my credit card
statements because every time i check
there's something wrong yep and i'm like
so this just happens all the time and i
like can't practice people just take
money from you all the time and she's
very diligent about it and when we go
out to dinner she always checks the bill
and she always finds something but that
time i had the restaurant it was our
favorite restaurant and then we just uh
i had i called the head and was just
like yo put this on the bill
and they were so cool they did it and
then what did she say yeah we're married
it's like yes and we didn't get
we did not
yeah no yeah yeah yeah but um yeah
that's how it went down and it was so
cool so easy we went just went like it
was a random wednesday night by the way
thank you for doing something so some
this is how it should be done simple
clean
like i've had friends husbands that are
women that are in their late 30s whose
ovaries are rotting by the hour they're
right and they like
plan a scavenger hunt yeah it's like
it's like what do you do she's gotta
like go do an obstacle course in order
to get the ring like she's gotta go on a
fucking a lot of it's show for other
people and that's not how me and my wife
work at all we don't do that we don't
play that game yeah or there's just got
to be some it's all about your ego this
is all about because you want her to be
like and then he did this thing and he
did this thing and it's like meanwhile i
can't have biological children because
you were too busy
you know like coordinating some like
making me go do zumba i've married my
wife twice we're getting married again
we keep getting married
yeah
what is this no it's fun all my friends
love that we're together we all go
celebrate it we did it once miami won at
a courthouse and then once uh where this
year's 10 years so we're hitting vegas
come on yeah and my best friend who
introduced me and her has married us
every time and he's doing it in vegas as
elvis this year come on it's going to be
sick yeah
have there been been together for that
long 10 years has there been any you
know the goal i believe is like to
always grow together like hopefully
you're not the same person you were 10
years ago absolutely you know what i'm
saying but like has there been any like
evolution in y'all's like personal lives
that have been like oh you used to not
be like that but i i was in love with
that person but i'm in love with her too
you know i went through like a huge life
change with my wife and it was massive i
lost my mom out of nowhere at the age of
and um
when that happened i also lost my dad um
not physically but like
who he was and um
my wife held me down the hardest and no
one has ever done what she's done other
than my mom in a weird way uh for like
but she's the best person i know my wife
is i like
i i play no games in like diminishing
who she is because like she really is
one of the strongest people i've ever
met
that's so cool
this is messing up my whole paradigm
this is fucking with my whole thing why
they
got that well you know there's certain
things as you move through the world
you're like look we're kind of meant to
be lone wolves you're about to be on
your own after a certain amount of time
neurochemically you're just not going to
be into each other you know what i'm
saying like i think some people
or people that didn't see have a
blueprint of a positive relationship can
never
have the coolest relationship i've ever
seen they are growing all together they
are so happy they still travel they keep
things exciting and i do think that
there is a little bit of you know not to
you know
be a victim about it but i think when
you've seen so many divorces
i've seen a lot i think divorce is
absolutely the right thing to do instead
of screaming in front of your children
you know i think it's cool to show your
children look if something doesn't work
call it like that's a healthy okay thing
a lot of your friends have mommy's house
and daddy's house like that's the mature
thing to do like marriage was invented
before when the life expectancy was 30
like forever used to mean like 15 years
not
you know 70 years and so like i think
often divorce is the healthiest thing
for everybody involved in the kids
especially if you got married young and
it was just you've turned into a
different person or whatever or a
child's in danger or something but
i think when you see so many in a small
amount of time you see everything as
kind of like disposable in a way so to
me
like fighting or like when something
hard comes up like it's just going to
end anyway why not just call it like my
i may i think that's stone in the town i
don't need to take away no i am it's my
default my default is what are we doing
i'm not doing this like i'm very
defeatist about it i find those are the
times where you like build the most
where it's just like
i mean there's times where we went
head-to-head and but at the same time
like when we came out of it when we went
through the steps of figuring it out
yeah we both learned something but how
do you know when a you know i think the
key to a
healthy relation number one respect is
the number one thing yeah and what you
just said was like it was so cool to
hear and i hope everybody listens i joke
about my wife and i say things on stage
and like i like and i've had i've had
people even comment but like i won't
play with that what i say on stage like
is like me and my wife know about this
we we say yes this isn't making fun uh
like yes exactly but i've had people
when i come off stage say something i
was like yo you don't get to say that
don't ever do that yeah yeah
that's what we're doing here i can say
it we've agreed on it like but i think
that's like that's very much who i am
just admitting he's married is already
revolutionary i am blown away
how often i come off stage and even how
much i talk about it how women are
towards me
it blows my mind and know what blows my
mind even more whitney this fucking
drives me crazy how many girls are in my
dms and they're married on their um
they're married that's a big thing
they're married on their instagram yeah
i'm not there's a couple things number
one i see the allure of
like a married man i'm not interested in
married men
don't get it think it's gross but there
is a little bit of like he's not afraid
of commitment like he's married you know
what i'm saying there's something hot
about a guy being married but that
person's off limits and also
there is you know nicole byer and i
talked about this ages ago like love her
the best dude the best there is a little
bit of a um
the open relationship thing i feel like
it's happening i don't buy it i call
bullshit like i don't get it unless it's
like a team situation there's a lot of
hollywood couples we're like look we're
better together let's just let's just
be together be platonic date other
people and keep our assets like it's
gonna be a big mess
you know we've got like lots of
businesses and llc's and shit like let's
just stay together and date other people
so i'm like i've seen that where it's
like oh you're just a business that's
how you get cancer
ritual union you guys know that not only
do i love ritual protein powder and
ritual vitamins which i have been on for
thrice years three years even before we
had a podcast that's a long time okay a
lot of people say
i look better than ever
cowinkydink who knows maybe who knows
i'm not making claims like that right
you are
right but i want to talk about that
that's on you
i want to talk about protein powder
because i take umbrage
with men that have five six sometimes
seven
vats
of cylindrical yeah protein powder
psychosis and it's like
like terminator protein right right
right they're like this one has bull
piss in it yeah
like car crusher nascar protein powder
this one's called broken spine you're
like i don't know if i want that but
ritual protein powder is it's easy it's
delicious it's just
you just put it in there you mix it up
and you leave me tell you something i as
a as a seeker of red flags mm-hmm
i not only count the number of protein
powder on a man's fridge area because
that'll tell me how everything i need to
know about his level of commitment why
do you have seven protein powders
they'll do the same thing or do they not
i don't know i'll look at the
ingredients and i'm like what is
benzodiazepine so you need variety and
i'm only one person no but i'm almost
like what are all these z's with ritual
no no no no no no made traceable no
added sugar no sugar alcohols soy free
gluten-free formulated with non-gmo
ingredients you can actually pronounce
the ingredients and douchebag free
customer base and if you're subscribing
to ritual you're getting it like you
know that's that's that's a not a red
flag that's a green flag you're not a
soy boy you're just smart now if you do
have a bunch of protein powders you can
still reach out to me
we're not completely writing you off
just try virtually still has more of her
life to waste
so
that's our blunder making the ritual
prouder right now so why not shake up
your ritual to make something new less
scary uh ritual offers a money back
guarantee no risks if you're not 100
in love you will be fine you'll get
through this don't panic plus my
listeners get 10 off during your first
three months just visual visualize how
great your life is about to get because
it is
visit
ritual.com
whitney to add essential protein today
without looking like a douche bag to the
people that come into your home oh i
think this smoothie bring in the
smoothies
that's ritual.com whitney a ritual
subscription is actually a very good
christmas gift or a holiday gift i don't
think we're allowed to say christmas i
said merry christmas on a tv show and i
was asked to go into hr
and i meant it and i lost sleep over it
but you know why
because at the time i didn't have
brooklyn and
i thought it was i would thought i was
stressing out because i was gonna get
fired but i was just tai tai
i i was not getting quality sleep until
brooklyn came into my life you spend a
third of your life in bed
i'm spending
more yeah actually
i spent 95 years out of my life in bed
and the other five percent in other
people's beds yeah so the best gift the
best gift i believe is the gift of
comfort whether that's a hug and blanket
form
yes that weighted comforter is insane i
love the way to comfort ourselves
the robes are phenomenal and i've
stopped stealing them from hotels
because now i have brooklyn no need yeah
we we travel with ours all of us i'm
obsessed brooklyn has got options for
everyone on your list that would be such
a good gift the robes i might do that
also they have candles eye masks like
they have lots of great gifts and if
you're looking for more ways to stay
cozy check out not our podcast uh or my
voice check out brooklyn's candles you
know that i am a candle
free
uh
the key to candles is not only do they
have to smell amazing without being
overpowering they can't burn really fast
this burn you have it it burns for like
i'm like it's never done it's never out
it's wild i had a brooklyn candle and i
loved it so much and then my a guy i
started dating took a a poop in my
bathroom and while i was napping and lit
it to like negate the poop smell and it
burned it for hours and it was still
rocking and rolling the candle lasted
longer than your relationship it did
it's still going one time i
made a poo poo in a guy's uh bathroom
that i hooked up with and i couldn't
flush it and it wouldn't go down so i
put it in a baggie and threw it out the
window same z's but in a dixie cup
i scooped it out with a dixie cup and
threw it out on broadway in new york
city i should be arrested
we should send them brooklyn and
thank yous
sorry
yeah well unrelated
check out the gift guide to find out the
perfect present at every price point go
to brooklyn.com and use promo code
whitney to get twenty dollars off with a
minimum purchase of a hundred dollars
that's brooke
b-r-o-o-k-l-i-n-e-n.com and enter promo
code whitney for 20 off your first order
that's brooklyn.com promo code
whitney now back to ricky
did you used to fight when you were kid
a lot really yeah
it's i've actually punched a few
comedians in the face
yeah okay yeah but that stopped are they
what's up once i made money because i
knew they consumed me
and that's the only to be clear that's
the only reason it has stopped but i
also think a lot of people need to learn
how to feel like it's honestly there if
i may i'm sorry to take such a
pro-violent stance here but
there's a lot of people where you're
like all this person needs is just to
get punched in this face one time once
that your only problem is that you've
never been hit in the face yeah but i uh
kevin spacey had just gotten punched in
the face he spoke at my high school
graduation keep going
so you're the reason this happened had
you just punched him in the face like
you did everybody else maybe those kids
no it was like two people and it was
always disrespecting my wife
and this was before we were married and
by the way and that is like literally
like that
why is that wrong is that wrong is that
well she's not a comic and i don't let
people play that like if you're not
going to start throwing insults at her
because she's not going to come back at
you
that is wildly fascinating because it's
like you're not that's not she's not on
limits no yeah she's not like you don't
get to hunt things that don't know
they're being hunted like they're not
you know what i'm saying yeah you don't
get to do that but i i i honestly i hate
that in a way that like i used to like
just go physical right away because
that's like a lot of what i saw growing
up
it's fascinating and so is it something
that like you felt like because the
ways that i was taught to sort of solve
problems would be very reactive and
because i you know violence wasn't
something i was necessarily capable of i
was on the other side of a lot but you
know for me it was like taking action
and so a big thing in the allen on
recovery is don't just do something sit
there right because you're gonna make
the problem worse and like just tolerate
the discomfort and forgive the person
all the like sort of tools that you
develop in order to not like make a
bigger mess and so i know what it's like
to i would go out of body i do it a
little bit with animal rescue stuff if
like i have no choice in the matter so
when there's a dog in a hot car
like with the windows up like i have
hammers in my car people know this and
the glass cutting stuff and i just go
apoplectic and i don't really remember
it afterwards like that's how that's how
it would go so one time uh because like
i know what that is it's like an out of
body thing yes and then you're like what
have i done you know it's like a crazy
um uh one time i was leaving a fucking
this is so embarrassing i left an aca
meeting because there's like churches
that have on the weekends like different
12-step meetings it'll be like sex
addiction overeaters like all in the
same place right and um
and there was a uh dog in a hot car
i like smash it open i pick up the dog
and i like stormed into where it seemed
like this person would have been parked
and i'm like who's dog is this no like
that's my dog and i was like what the
fuck and i started going ape and it was
a codependence anonymous meeting and
codependents anonymous like the people
with the lowest self-esteem who were
like abused and i was like what the fuck
is wrong with you and uh and i like
don't remember it it's that kind of it's
like a blind rage yes where i go to
another place yes and i don't recognize
if you were to show me on the
surveillance camera like i wouldn't
recognize myself like my posture it's
different
yeah it's actually it's absolutely that
and even the words i say like it's not
even how i speak
fascinating
i start talking about like i'm like this
is illegal this is like i started
talking about how it's illegal and which
states and why i'm like i don't even
know i think i guess i
and things that i would be so
embarrassed to do so scared to do
i do
and if whether it's adrenaline or some
like primordial instinct or whatever it
is
i lose it i think it's just like i i've
i grew up in a place where like i mean
my dad fought my baseball coaches so
many times he became my baseball coach
so
like dude i did aau basketball all the
fathers would beat the shit out of the
coaches it was wild to watch it was
really crazy yeah because they were like
living vicariously through their
daughters they would like french braid
their hair and shit and if they didn't
get a chance to play they would like
fight the coaches it was wild yeah yeah
shout out hbqvb that's what i play did
your um dad was he qualified to coach
baseball yeah is it great he did
you know i just like that there's like a
show
this guy seems kind of crunk let's have
this guy but uh yeah just just a tough
guy yeah he's a very tough guy his whole
family were tough guys and then so what
because to me i don't think there's a
path for me uh in terms of
not having those outbursts when i see
that kind of animal abuse like i have
there's no path to recovery for me i'm
not attempting it
but
i i don't have the ability to restrain
myself when i see something it's
actually something i love that i think
judd taught me was just like why are
people doing these things and most of it
comes from pain pain exactly so like
this guy is over here
roasting my wife or even saying just
something completely inappropriate to
her and it's like oh he's he's this is
not
this is not
my wife did nothing
but what is the alternative
to go hey stop
uh i don't i don't at this point i mean
we would probably just walk away at this
my wife always walks away she has no she
has no
physicality i like or she hates it when
i do it as well but um
i don't know i don't know
i guess i don't i i'm it's been years i
just have work to do because to me like
or also there's a well that's something
in life danger you're talking about
something that's very much in life
danger a dog can die especially out here
in california when i see dog like
voiceless because it's also with
children so something that is voiceless
that doesn't have any tools to advocate
for itself or open a door or like you
know i just it's like a sexual trauma
survivor thing where it's like it's like
dude if you're gonna abuse someone that
can run away or get in a car and go like
that's that's adult business that you'll
work out but if it's someone that like
your wife who's like i'm
is
vulnerable
uh she's gonna be okay
no she's gonna be fine but i don't like
it's like pick on someone your own size
it's kind of boils down to that it does
i don't like like a dog or abusing an
animal like what the fuck or a child
like what are you doing it's like
interesting that i even said that i
thought on this bucket but i said it
before on other podcasts but like i kind
of have shame in it now what just having
five fought in the past
especially in like comedy clubs and the
rest that that's interesting i mean i
i've never heard about it crystal
stefano was making fun of me the other
day when i did his podcast because i was
once thrown through like a ticket booth
yeah i have a mouth on me when i get
going i'm kind of obsessed with that
yeah
yeah i was like 23 24. and let me ask
you
what okay so how do you how did you get
like a handle on the reactivity as
someone that has not gotten a handle on
it and as i i moved consequences
you know i grew up with a lot of people
that have like made big big mistakes one
of my friends rob tried to rob a bank
he was on heroin tried to rob a bank not
it out and then the police showed up so
he was just like asleep waiting for the
money
mm-hmm so like we should rob a blood
bank
why
because i'm obsessed i'm obsessed with
that you drink because you're in the
illuminati a baby bloodbath now i have
confirmed
what's happening here i like hollywood
and look um i uh yeah i'm obsessed with
blood banks and i like i i i feel like i
was like working on this for like a
movie pitch for a while if someone
someone that was trying to rob a bank
and they got like they went to a blood
bank by accident and they like
just like got all this they don't do
they just ran away those blood um and uh
i but i'm just fascinated okay so you
had consequences that that is a big one
and it's something that like you can't
teach like there's no way to go like
just stop this before you hit rock
bottom before the consequences get so it
was also like i met my wife's family
where like there was none of that zero
of that there was no acting like that
that was so
that's from movies that happens in
movies yes
yeah
so when when when you just like are
around people but here's what i'll say
when you punch someone
this is a gun she shoots me with when i
interrupt no it's fine
i want to hear the question though you
had it you the person that
that came for your wife
needed to be punished you gave him a
consequence so like i always like to say
like sometimes when i do crazy things it
gives the other person an opportunity to
learn
so i'm really just a teacher
to this day um when you punch them in
the face you might be healing them
in a way yes
he apologized he apologized to my wife
he like called up and apologized to all
of us
because to me one of them right now when
i look on twitter and i look at like
trolls and people and talk about i'm
like i just think there's
not enough people just getting punched
in the face or like you know what goes a
long way
like a face squeeze
i mean that would get a punch in the
face if you squeeze my face
jesus
christ are you wild just squeezing
somebody's face dude it goes have you
done that yes to who oh name them
uh one was um a uh
like a
fake like a house manager at this
facility that was abusing animals and
they were like the the barn manager or
something and i was like look me in the
face and tell me that's true he was
shocked it was it it really does disarm
people well you have a presence about
you and then you doing that that would
throw me for days like someone won't
look at me in the face and you like grab
their chin it's like what's your problem
why can't you look at my face and say
that say it again to my face like if you
just hold their chin
you know what i'm saying yeah i
you know what else you can do just kiss
him
no have you seen the changeling no dude
the most gangster performance i've ever
seen in the changeling the guy that
played the child rapist do you know the
changeling no okay
you're just
i'm about to ruin your day okay okay
let's go this is based on a true story
is this a
show or just no this is a movie with
angelina jolie where in the 20s all
these kids love her all these kids were
disappearing and a uh i guess psychotic
child rapist murderer was picking them
up and being like oh my parents are like
you know like i know your parents and
they asked me to come pick you up they
got whatever got all these kids took him
back to his place hacked them up
or i i don't know exactly i'll have to
find i can google in a second and um so
if only there was a machine that could
tell me the actual story people are
listening to this like that's not even
close to the story if you're trying to
convince me to kiss comics in the mouth
when they pissed my wife off this is
going to be weird
get over here keith robinson
wildest power move of all time easily
you know what dan naderman
those big juicy
in your nasty ass comments
cherry chapstick
thank you get over here got that
changeling is 1980 nope that's not it
sorry that it was a remake that angelina
jolie's was a remake
2008 mystery crime driver directed
produced scored by clint eastwood and
who cares a story was based on real life
events you know clint eastwood leaves
every day at five regardless of where
they are the car comes regardless where
they're on the cover that's awesome
leaves every day at five that's
incredible walks off that's so cool i
know that's
by now
stars angelina jolie is a woman united
with a boy who she realizes not her
missing son when she tries to
demonstrate this to the police and city
authorities she's verified as delusional
labeled as an unfit mother and confined
with something i can't see this yes
right so they bring her a kid and it's
not her kid yeah and she's like this
isn't my child and they're like yeah it
is you're crazy did you ever hear that
story where they kind of like they
adopted a kid somebody a dog a real
dwarf like a russian dwarf yeah like a
25 year old i'm obsessed with that story
i would i would i wouldn't even be mad
i'd be like you're driving i was just
like you're driving now but it was like
a little like serial killer
oh was it
yeah i thought it was just a dwarf that
what are we allowed to call them that
nope uh what is it little girl what is
it a little person oh keebler elf what
are we saying oh man what is it little
sprite little buddy my buddy on my buddy
a dwarf adopted by a couple who claims
she's quote psychopathic a psychopathic
adult posing as a child is now living
with the new family natalia has a rare
form of dwarfism is at the center of a
bizarre case which served a little bit
apparently she started like terrorizing
them yeah yeah yeah i i really love that
she's from the ukraine
the story i mean she was like i can't be
a mail order i might as well be a baby
i am a baby not a male guy i could be
male 1 frankly
i'm i'm glad i didn't meet her i would
have killed her and drank her blood for
no reason
yeah it wouldn't have been good anything
like i even put ice in it killed a
person
what a waste
uh she she basically uh hold on percy
she legally changed her age of 22 court
records showed they withdrew the okay
where's the dirt why isn't there a new
site that just gives me the bullet
points like cliff notes where's the dirt
she uh what did she do that was sketchy
though she tried to poison me uh she
alleges the imposter tried to poison her
pushed her against an electric fence and
threatened to kill her other children in
her sleep natalya said have smeared
blood on mirrors and tried to jump out
of a moving car
i mean that sounds hilarious maybe she
was
in the new jackass movies maybe she was
just this little person
yeah like can we reach out to her
looking for some content she'd make
statements and draw pictures saying she
wanted to kill family members roll them
up in a blanket she can't execute any of
these things take her crayons away and
put them in the backyard yeah it's just
like okay is it a threat if the person
is too small to
do all these things
just hide in the door knobs in the house
yeah like
just sort of like
like just watch your achilles heel
put the knives on a higher shelf chucky
like just look on the bed before you get
in the back she was standing over people
in the middle of the night
how low was your bed that she was
standing
up and my adopted kit but also it's just
like give it back dwarf there has to be
a receipt the door can be
just the one way to look at that receipt
the dwarf was not hovering over your bed
you looked over and she was there she
wasn't you know i'm saying how low is
your bed that a three-foot dwarf is
looking down at you please stop saying
dwarf yeah it's not to work what is it a
little little person
and you just lost five minutes of the
podcast
i've said so much worse shit look my
heart is in the right place i saw her
putting chemicals bleach windex
something like that in my coffee and
asked her what are you doing she said
i'm trying to poison you she sounds
hilarious but also how much like it's a
baby why is it able to get around clorox
i have child locks on everything around
my job why didn't you it seems like you
didn't think she was a baby this is bad
like you parented this fake adult uh
baby that poorly like you weren't ready
for the toddler you thought you were
getting yeah i'm saying thank god she
was an adult or you'd have a dead baby
on your hand yeah because we'd be
playing with laura
like how was she able to get out of her
crib at night no stand over here you
don't have the net over it you don't
have the baby what's going on that this
adult you thought was a baby was doing
all this adult shit yeah she would make
statements and draw pictures okay that's
really interesting
if my kid ever came in and just started
making statements
but see this is i have a statement to me
i want to kill everybody
why did it take you so long to figure
out she was an adult like babies don't
make statements
here this is shady her quote i saw her
putting chemicals comma bleach comma
windex who has just chemicals
i mean everybody has like bleach i know
but chemicals comma bleach comma windex
why does this baby have so much free
range
but what is chemicals why do you have so
many random chemicals in your house yeah
it's like this is why this is why i'm
obsessed with writing that's why i'm
obsessed with comedy and getting really
like granular and surgical when it like
chemicals like no one says that unless
they're hiding something or lying you
wouldn't say she was putting chemicals
in like what chemicals you know windex
bleach
jim saying you don't have the specifics
so you said something general and no one
talks like that
how does this child man
not have a show
how are we not fully following them
hold on
let's see little people big world
okay
um oh god i look too too who's this this
is nelk boy you're calling steve will do
it right now if he's gonna answer it
wow this would be i know this is why
it's incredible
i'm very excited about this really no it
seems like he's not he just sent you his
phone number
wow well i went on instagram and said
can you uh text me
um i'm trying to facetime you
he said hey it's steve will do it
that's his name that's his eve it says
hey he's not he's not from canada
actually though he's the only one that's
uh the one that's not he's from florida
he's like a real like florida person oh
wow
he like has all does that mean like you
know florida people
what they they see jesus in their title
what does that mean florida people yeah
i feel like florida people florida is
gets a very bad rap i'm a florida
defender
um because i think there's crazy people
everywhere there's little florida's in
every state
yes but where that hot it's a problem
it's that hot
what about they're cold they're their
brains are melting
they're just getting sun year-round
what about
phoenix what are you talking about
the only place where white people get
ashy
it's crazy
phoenix is wild dude phoenix is wild i
went to shows in phoenix and like they
have to have sprinklers for the people
yeah they they water people they have to
water people like there's sprinklers up
top just spraying water like because
people would just pass away orange tan
people then they're just molting
everyone is in shorts all the time the
one thing i cannot do and they have guns
it's florida with more guns
and but they can't pick up their guns
because they're hot
you can't leave your guns out in the sun
dude you're like fucking touch my head i
just burned myself trying to kill
someone
florida's florida is is a different it's
a different beast yes yeah it's true but
i also think that there's like parts of
florida that are like there's parts of
florida that are like more like southern
parts of florida that are more like
cuban parts of florida that are more
like douche tool baggy like it's just so
many different things to me yeah it's
great my brain like i for some reason i
like but not one of those things you
said is florida educated
a lot of them are very educated
i'm not i can't afford it number one
number two i they have not approached me
which makes me feel like i'm not famous
and it's hurtful and also i don't even i
don't pay
commissions to my
agents unless they procure the job i'm
not going to pay
like a church
you know what i'm saying
yeah i don't like to talk about them
really yeah
because they're there i'm into
scientology i'm glad it exists because
my deal is the kind of people that would
be vulnerable to that i want them all in
one building
okay they're they're doing a great
service to society because if if you
weren't
whatever it don't take i mean it is very
fucked up that like they don't i mean
john travolta's kid is dead
i i'm a catholic yeah like it's wild
but sorry i i thought your word like a
dark it's just gonna hit you in the neck
i don't give a fuck dude do i look like
i give a fuck you think scientology
scientology you live on a dead end i
would stop talking shit
i would shut the fuck up right now
yeah i just i'm too tired to do it
um i just don't uh i don't know i i
think it's such a like
people being scared of it is just so i
don't know i'm just kind of like all
right come on did you watch any of the
lena yeah i did i watched all that and i
know her i know leah and i've seen it
all and it is horrific but i just think
we got to stop being scared of these
people like it's wild
they're doing their own thing i'm not
doing it what are you doing you're gonna
deep fake me
into a porn great that's already
happened my nudes have been leaked like
good word you know who's gotta fucking
do this someone that has nothing to lose
am i the person that's gonna do it
what
i would like to get the kids out of
scientology i don't think you should if
you're born into scientology should live
there and get fruit you want to get them
out of cars and scientology don't they
have like
hot cars hot cars and scientology get
those kids out of there don't like the
idea that they have like fruit flies on
their eyeballs i saw that in one of the
documentaries going clear right that
someone like their baby was in the care
of like the scientology daycare center
like the scientology gymboree and uh the
kids were like had bugs on them and
stuff yeah that's not good i don't like
that shit i don't put bugs on my kids
i'm good
i am totally fine with
crazy adults that otherwise would be
making a mess in the world going into
one building and staying there okay you
know what i'm saying yeah it's like a
voluntary prison that's kind of how i
feel about l.a
what is your problem with l.a i feel
like the only place i've never seen
anybody ever read a newspaper
yeah we're green no you're full of
yourselves
no when i'm in l.a times i read it
you're talking about it i was in the
covered style section i read it yeah i
just said it's a weird town for me yeah
it feels like high school
interesting well because it's very
clicky because you have to drive you
don't get to just like no because your
social life goes up with your job
interesting yeah but a lot of
narcissistic celebrities like to be
friends with not famous people because
it doesn't threaten their ego
a lot of a lot of very famous people
like to surround themselves with losers
yeah to be fair yeah
seen enough of that it was the most
toxic answer to that she responds i'm
like no no
celebrities don't really hang out
together the insecure ones like to
surround themselves with like ugly
people so they look prettier in
comparison that's true yeah 100
true
you're not a threat you're so intense
dude you're intense am i
i don't think so did you not think
did you not think i was intense before
this no really no
huh no not not as intense as you are
like intense uh it's not bad uh-huh but
it's just it's it's funny
really yeah i feel like i'm actually
bummed about this because i was like why
well here we were gonna have christina
ricci earlier today we were supposed to
do two shows wow and so i was gonna be
like all like prepared and i like had my
shit and i was gonna be in like a more
on mood i felt like and then
i don't know i feel i feel i'm annoyed
that i'm meeting for the first time and
not being funny what are you talking
about we're having an awesome
conversation well podcasts are like it's
like come watch comedians be kind of
boring you know what i mean like i
always feel like i'm being boring
because it's a comic i'm like i'm
supposed to be making a joke every 20
seconds yeah instant gratification yes
but this is more like i'm always like is
this being boring is this being boring
like it's us being vulnerable
yeah you know i like that and i'm trying
to know one of my favorite comics ever
mike d stefano he used to be like the
most vulnerable guy in the world but he
was also just a badass but i don't i
didn't want to put you in a situation
where i was like coming in like don't be
like oh god i have to be funny on this
like i don't like feeling pressure to be
funny on podcast so i don't want to put
that on you no
i'm not funny
you're special i am actually annoyed by
how funny it was okay am i getting
ghosted by the steve we'll do it that's
amazing that's incredible there must be
a ghost or something wrong with my phone
because he hasn't responded yeah that's
what it is there must be something going
on and this is you reaching out for love
imagine next time
please
please you know he like hangs out with
six nine he's a maniac the rapper that
snitched on the whole bloods game in new
york yeah yeah yeah
steve will do it steve will do it does
he have a girlfriend
i'm not sure oh he's cute
oh he's hanging out with addison ray
mm-hmm i know who that is
dude i went to this is just funny to me
so i'm not i went to a jake paul fight
how'd it go great i'm obsessed with them
mm-hmm i love logan paul i love the
whole exact internet i think the whole
internet world going on right now is
absolutely fascinating i
am fascinated by people that because i
think this is our goal
is that people love you even if they
don't disagree with something you did or
one of your takes or one of your actions
they still fuck with you
because they respect you number one the
basis for all sustainable relationships
number two which is that is also my fear
this is really gross i know but i'm
worried because
there are certain human nature things
that make you fall out of love with
people and you can't fix it and i was
madly in love with a guy once and we
were walking to new york and he tripped
and fell and i was it was over
wow it was a bummer just watching
somebody come fall
a little like it's just like you're not
a father like you can't do that i saw
somebody fall up not too long ago i was
on a plane and the turbulence hit and he
went up was it christina
or tom sagura he looked like a demon
[Laughter]
but it's like little things like that
like like if i see like a farmer's tan
i'm just like
yeah like some kind of
primordial like amygdala my wife is such
a lady if i watched her like spit i
don't know what that was dude some
things are just irreversible it's not
it's not you it's just human nature like
biology is sexist i'm sorry like it just
is and like some things you can get
through but other things you just like
can't you know
fair
i'm sorry am i am i a bad person i don't
know am i homophobic no okay what makes
homophobic it's just like what you don't
like to do sexually i just know it's
just like i don't like you do it like if
you want that done dude that's even
crazier just
plowing away at
look at my thumb i mean i've got like i
can't like i can't i don't want to do
that like there's just this i can't yeah
you know what i mean
no
i'm not eating ass like that's a really
big part of it now that's a that's like
in the mix that's on the menu welcome to
2021 no thank you
no hold on what am i oh
logan paul i love
never met him yeah but you like jake i
went to his fight but how do you know
about him you're just like a big fight
person i just love uh the internet um
like uh a behavior of what's going on
[Music]
logan paul mom
hi
where are you
you're in your sex dungeon
yeah i noticed your face on me i did i
was just talking about about you with a
hilarious comedian named ricky velez
and uh
we were talking about your brother and i
was like i love them
why do i love them so much
i don't think you do i don't think you
do whitney i do what do you mean i don't
this is
you're the only man i've ever loved
no i i've made multiple attempts to hang
out with you and like even wow just hang
out and you've always said you've always
made excuses
yeah i'm like hold on let me just get a
facelift and we'll hang out
look at you looking for love you're
perfect just the way you are let me just
get lipo and butt injections and i will
totally hang out with you when it's all
healed up
i like you just the way you are when you
shouldn't have to change the thing to
feel beautiful are you in a barn
yeah i'm an adult oh by the way ricky
half puerto rican lives in puerto rico
now yeah that's tight
thanks for supporting my family
is this live on a podcast no we can cut
it out it's not live it's we don't live
what is it no no you should you should
not cut it out because i don't think
you're doing i think you'd be doing your
audience a disservice
i don't know is jake available
yeah he's here do you want to talk to
him sure
we were talking because he was saying he
went to one of jake's fights
and he was saying how much he loved him
and then i was like um
i'm gonna be i'm gonna be honest i just
use my own brother for clout he's not
even here he's not even here oh it's
embarrassing
what's what is he doing barstool
david
was your guys podcast so boring you had
to facetime someone good at it or what
you know wow
i first of all the guy from nelk is
trying to date me so easy watch it
wait which one which one steve steve
oh oh
i don't know he's kind of fun he's kind
of hot dude
i think you should date steve i don't
know
he's sick
i think you would are you a degenerate
gambler and drinker
emotional gambler she drinks hard
kombucha i don't think he drinks a lot
of hard kombucha is he um what like
what's his thing what's his what is it
so i hear you about the whole thing i
like you because you have horses i'm
actually at dinner right now so i have
to go
[Applause]
i have to go
i have to go bye gotta go
i will not be hung up on by logan paul
he talks to you like he has credits
okay we do have to let him go but like i
hung up on him right right yeah that was
my
i was not i'm a huge fan of him i think
what they're doing is by logan paul no
he was eating they're on the east coast
it's different he said his mom was there
when you you picked up imagine you you
you met his mom
look at that who should i dave date
logan or nelq i would love you and steve
will do it together
love it i would love it what what if he
like doesn't he'll do it he'll do it all
you pussy he'll do it you don't need ass
he'll do it steve will do it you should
spend some time and watch his videos
okay you'll really really really
tim loves him tim brings uh brings him
up a lot yeah no he's he's i just like
my thing is like i don't invest too much
in youtubers let's like see the old
tweets now like i don't want to you know
well that's his thing he you like you
can't cancel him yeah yeah he's one of
those time investing in people and then
you're like oh you did blackface for
halloween like a couple years back like
i feel like you have to research on
people before you bring them in your
life who does it this year blackface
somebody always does it um it's so
interesting you say that um me
wow
well this has been fun
i'm glad i got to meet you before it all
goes down
and i am not leaving you're leaving
um i am obsessed with you you're special
i want to talk to you way more about it
but it is i don't want to ruin any of
the jokes because i did want to like
talk about some of the bits i'm glad
that i didn't because it is so
i'm so ex i'm so first of all the
highest compliment i can ever give to
someone is your special made me jealous
thank you i know that means a lot to me
as a comment
it like pissed me off it was like
and like it was just like that drug deal
in the ocean just trust me it goes on
for so it just keeps
it's so funny for so long
it's such a long time and no one does
that anymore it's like here's my three
jokes on religion my three jokes on
twitter i know storytelling's my thing
like i love storytelling it is like in
i don't want to say old school but it's
like it's like it feels like an instant
classic thank you that means a lot and
you know what like the drug dealer joke
i was like dude this is a joke that like
you're gonna have when you're on doing
another hour on your next tour people
are going to have to deal or joke like
it's the kind of joke that you can hear
again and again like burke christian's
like machine bed or whatever they want
him to tell it like thank you so much
that's really cool to me yeah and your
dumbass fucking it's so
specific and um
yeah it made me mad it made me want to
work harder thank you that means a lot
but i also understand this the first
thing i'm ever putting out yes and then
you are doing a movie with judd apatow
another one yeah we are working on
something right now yeah amazing and i
really love him he's like he's the best
guy in the world i really really like
him i he still scares like i can't get
over being a fan can we write something
yeah i have a really good idea
oh god it's good what do i play no i'm
not going to do it i'm not fucking did
he say hi hey mom when he had yeah but i
think
hey mom like what's up ma or was it hey
mom i heard them at the end
i do have to go i do but the other thing
is you need to stop bringing comics in
here why because they're
fogged
yeah and you don't need them knowing
where you live i don't like somebody
that's from new york that should have
seen it
no it feels like
can you imagine someone like honestly
imagine someone trying to kill me
can you imagine no no just be like
they'd be like i'll do it they would be
like this is too intense
hold on can you get it get on the ring
cam let's get on the ring cam like get
it like i'm getting a netflix
documentary out of this like i like film
it and uh that's pretty wild i know i
did have someone that wanted to kill me
and it was funny when andrew schultz was
on last time i'm gonna fucking support
him we're gonna bleep his name out he
does not need to get more famous it's
getting i love him he um
uh i'm glad he doesn't live in l.a
because he would for sure have a like
neon green porsche and uh i was like uh
there was this guy that was trying to
kill me or whatever and he was like you
know uh if i can't have you no one can
like that kind of crazy person but i do
have a robot that looks exactly like me
and he was joking about like you like
you'd be the worst person to kill
because there's like another one of you
like the guys in jail they're like wait
you killed whitney cummings the girl
with the robot so do you have to kill
the robot too
i like how casually you act like having
a robot that looks like you is normal
yeah welcome to the fun house yeah
it's the most normal thing i've said in
the last three hours thank you for
letting me keep you so long i hope this
will fuck up uh our friendship or not at
all yeah i'm very happy we have a
friendship now yeah i'm so dude when
steve hit you back can you hit me yeah
we're gonna be a group chain cool here's
my deal for now we're in like a mormon
non-section i'm in your you like you're
gonna coast you're gonna be on all the
texts i'm gonna be like i just never get
to sign off on this cool because i
thought you said what's up mom but you
said mom that was jake paul i need him
to locate logan i need him to like
translate what's being said to me okay
you know what i'm saying i need to i
need like a dating translator because i
always see things wrong but you're in a
relationship
when does this come out don't write off
um i love you don't write elephants
ricky velez this special is fucking
brilliant it's called here's everything
it is out it is streaming now king of
staten island you've probably already
seen it but go see it again and now
i mean you did kind of
steal the show not in a way that
diminishes anyone else's performance
thank you you were able to shine without
outshining which is the key to success
in this business
keep the gap in your teeth
or else people be uh intimidated
[Music]
four four four six
[Applause]